now let's pick teams I've got a ton of
work you can just leave me out this year
what how naive do you think we are
you're not participating so you can
sneak under our noses and steal a
victory like Santiago did last year I'm
going to my desk heister dumb so what
are you planning for the ice the only
thing I'm planning is getting my work
done sure you are come clean or we'll
tell everybody about your mistress I
don't have a mistress you don't but
you're so good looking what's the point
there is the small issue of me losing my
partner now Terry I know that you were
upset that no one picked you earlier not
what happened regardless please be my
partner please please please please
please please no I said dumb and I have
work to do you're dumb and I have Heist
to do yeah overreacted damn it look who
I found hiding in the interrogation room
this guilty son of a steal your
sergeant I wasn't hiding I was doing my
work Hitchcock and Scully were with me
were they or perhaps were they
distracted by your brilliant Pizza ruse
totally distracted I ate two whole pies
folded them up like tacos your suspect
number one Jeffords whatever what ever
spoken like a common criminal still a
long time till Sun up all I have to say
is whoever took that plaque you better
watch out come on Rosa
our heists dumb our Heist dumb of course
not that was a stupid question no Jake
it says heists are dumb
okay
the Oscar for best liar goes to you
that's not an Oscar's category what's
going on not to be harsh Sarge but
you're setting a terrible example for
your daughters and they're going to grow
up to be total failures you take that
back no she's right Jeffrey your
children are doomed where's the plaque
for the last time I don't know I've been
working here the whole time ask them
well actually well we both fell asleep
and Jeffers never woke us up coincidence
I don't need this you're not going
anywhere
none of you stand a chance against me no
courage no patience no brains and of
course a bald old man I'm younger than
you no come back for the bald thing I
see yeah I'm not doing the heist I'm out
right just like you were out last year I
was out last year as a setup for this
year you're good Jeffords but not good
enough in fact you're an idiot I should
have fired you long ago what relax Terry
chill out get your undies out of your
buns Rosa I am very disappointed in you
your approval means nothing to me copy
that and Terry I knew you were playing
last year was a setup hell yeah it was
I'm sick of you Amy and hope winning
you're all so damn smart but speaking of
yogurt you've eaten six GPS devices this
week you should definitely see a doctor
what wait I will only do this under one
condition Sergeant Jeffords agrees that
this will help his nerves yeah I mean I
would like to take my mind off the test
and maybe I'll win this year ah the
heist is already working Sergeant
Jefferson's recovered a sense of humor
hey there now they're locked in a range
of Affairs The Heist begins in five
minutes five minutes so this whole thing
was still last second I don't even have
any plans or supplies I have so many
plans and supplies I even have a victory
Banner that unfurls with a voice command
I can't say what but it's so cool I
thought this was a Spur at a moment fun
way to distract me from freaking out
about my exam well it wasn't exactly
hard to predict Sarge your catchphrase
is Terry hates tests it's true Terry
hates tests but the point is I planned
everything starting with scully's
bracelet it had to be the prize because
I have prepared the greatest reveal in
Heist history allow me to introduce you
to
hi I'm Merle an orange twin brother why
is Scully never mentioned he had a twin
before because no one talks about their
siblings with co-workers I told you
about my brother Lauren nope and I don't
want to learn about him and I already
forgot his name now let's go it's time
to Heist well that's terrifying now if
you'll excuse me I'm gonna hide the old
bracelet and win me this High don't you
mean when us this Heist oh Terence
unfortunately I do not
sorry Sarge it had to be this way why
the banner only has my name on it it's
really all about the banner it unfurls
by a voice command but I promise that I
will mention both you and Earl Scully in
my victory speech wait Earl's here yeah
he helped us with the heist I told Dad
son of a never gonna show his face
in New York again why are you running
towards the glass
just so you know Jake has the bracelet
in his pocket why would you tell them
that we're a team you locked me up yeah
but they didn't know that well stop
eating eggs and come help me with a
heist I'm not helping you why not is
this because I once betrayed you yes it
was our last interaction the plan worked
I got it oh my dude look like an
eye make sure it looks like I'm holding
you you're right there's no time we'll
do it later no he won't help me get this
paint off okay put your hands out and
I'll squirt you with a little makeup
remover
you're gonna be training me again why
because of the banner I thought you said
our friendship was more important yeah
that was obviously a lie the banner was
very expensive I don't have a lot of
money Sarge all right bye
don't make a lot of
noise
Terry you ripped yourself free yeah
maybe you should try a cupping me to a
stronger metal next time yeah I don't
know the relative strength of metals
come on why does Terry look like an
Oscar doesn't he he has the bracelet we
grabbed Mr hootsworth from cheddar and
swapped it for a fake Terry my betrayals
were all in good fun but this really
hurts hey now Terry's had enough of this
this was supposed to be just a fun game
but it turned you all into terrible
people betraying your husband putting
your friend in the mail Jake and Amy did
you guys buy each other any gifts this
year that weren't tasers yeah you all
pretended that this was all about
helping me with my tests but none of you
cared one bit you know what
you all suck oh no my voice command
Terry look out
okay I know that was bad but let's not
jump to any conclusions about whose
fault it was
[Music]
wow what a fun improvised songs wait
where is everyone
where are all the desks what is
happening what's happening is
you all suck
[Music]
Terry I'm out Terry is retiring from
heisting I don't have anything left to
prove after my win last year but we need
you what if one of us has a plan that
involves a big strong brute not a great
sales pitch Jake Terry is going out on
top fine
got a pedicure made a smoothie cause
Terry loves smoothies retiring early was
the best decision I have ever made well
you're missing out people are saying
this is the most fun Heist we've ever
done looks like Hulk keeps trying to put
his whole hand in cheddar's mouth while
Rosa Googles how to make a dog vomit
yeah like I said we're having a blast
maybe it was Terry who sent the flowers
yeah I really wanted to spend two
thousand dollars on Valentine's Day not
for my wife ah he admitted it just tell
us how you did it everything hinged on
Jeffords I needed him to drop out of the
heist so he'd have access to everyone's
Secrets which is why I set up a fake
interview for him you were working with
Williams but he left us in his office
which was critical to me gaining your
trust so you told me where the tube was
hidden Terry's really armed with that
information I texted Kevin who retrieved
the tube and handed it off to a person
who lured you all here and that person
was a dog and that dog was cheddar hold
up that big speech about how I'd make a
great captain that was all a lie no no I
meant every word of it in fact it's
exactly what I said to the real Williams
two weeks ago it's part of the reason he
decided to make you
the new captain of the nine nine wait
what is this fake two y'all need to cut
and be honest with me this is my life
we're talking about you want to know if
it's real open your gift
find out
a bag of fish great speech Terry but
we're kind of Trapped in here not for
long
I'm gonna Kool-Aid Man us the hell out
of here I thought you said that was
that was just not I just find it
demeaning it's actually very easy
foreign
[Music]
I'm not doing any more walls Jake we're
free fair enough I had to ask